hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 american contemporary fantasy movie
called the midas touch which follows a
man who is suddenly given an
extraordinary ability to seduce women
with a single touch he soon finds this
ability to be a curse instead of a
blessing the movie begins with a shy man
felix preparing for his day at a public
relations agency
his boss ron notices he has been ogling
a lady then mocks him for not knowing
anything about interacting with women
the lady is sarah walker ron's new
client
another woman jane initiates a
conversation with felix with a hope he
could flirt with her but he ultimately
fails leaving jane disappointed after
that sarah walks up immediately to felix
asking for his help to bring some of her
stuff home
felix agrees awkwardly so they walk
together with felix carrying boxes of
sarah's stuff while they are passing a
public park they encounter two magicians
sveatoslav and his assistant who are
marketing their seminars to female
visitors of the park
through the seminar they offer knowledge
on sexuality and how to enhance their
minds
meanwhile sarah and felix arrive at her
house where they are greeted by three
young women nevi elena and sarita
sarah instructs the women to perform
songs in front of felix he realizes they
are a cult but he goes along with a
choir trying to sing a verse
sarah then offers him a drink then
leaves to meet her husband leaving felix
disappointed
sarah's husband james walker is a
candidate for governor of the city they
hire felix's agency to shoot a campaign
video which felix helped give ideas for
however during the shoot james keeps
repeating wrong words blaming felix for
making faces that distract him
ron scolds felix and suggests james make
an impromptu speech instead
at home sarah talks with james that she
thinks ron is flirting with her to which
james replies that it is obvious since
sarah is such a beautiful woman however
when sarah wants to talk more about it
james dismisses her by saying he is too
tired from the election campaign and
wants to rest sveatoslav and his
assistant are conducting their seminar
they call for a volunteer and choose
sarita
however she does not follow the brief of
portraying beautiful women as stupid
frustrating sveatoslav
meanwhile in the seminar session with
the male audience svyatislav picks felix
as a volunteer
he instructs felix to flirt with amalia
his assistant to which felix ultimately
fails because he is very awkward and not
experienced
feeling humiliated felix goes to a bar
for a drink afterward where he sees a
man walking in with a few women
following him from behind the man
insists on having a break from these
women and dismisses them while he sits
next to felix
felix watches the man named samyaza with
amazement
samyaza tells him that he has a curse
that makes him extremely attractive to
women felix does not think it is a curse
but samyaza admits that he also thought
it was a blessing until he grew tired of
it he says he is tired of his situation
and wants to pass on the curse to
someone else
felix wants to receive the ability
samyaza says that they must perform a
silly dance and felix should say give it
to me then the ability is passed
after performing the ritual semyaza
attempts to touch a waitress but she
smacks him in the face instead of being
attracted to him indicating samyaza's
ability has been passed on felix is
confused as samyaza does not explicitly
teach him how to use this ability only
saying remember the touch as felix walks
through the park he passes several women
some bumping into him until making
physical contact
he immediately arouses them
even the vendor cart woman is highly
stimulated when she touches him for
taking his money
felix realizes the magic samyaza gave
him his work then tests it on several
different women who all end up chasing
after him he then sits next to a woman
and tries to touch her but with his hand
covered by a glove to which she does not
respond
however when he takes off the glove she
is aroused just like other women
after being chased by and sleeping with
many women of his desire felix grows
tired of his routine women keep chasing
after him yet he is too tired to
interact with them he even has bruises
from when he tried to outrun the women
during nightfall three tireless women
encounter him begging him to interact
with them again
felix demands to have time for himself
to rest before he meets them again
tomorrow
the next day at the office ron suspects
felix has been hanging out with women
and praises him for his improvement in
getting more experienced with females
ron then sees felix's three infatuated
followers trying to get to him which
amazes him even more felix arranges a
meeting with professor jones an expert
in cult rituals for an explanation of
his ability that disturbs his day-to-day
life the professor explains that the
ritual began in ancient times
specifically in ancient sumeria when a
young man uruk was fascinated by the
beauty of ashihara who did not seem to
be bothered by him determined to win her
heart he came to his spiritual advisor
for counsel saki
saki taught uruk the ritual of making
women attracted to him uruk succeeded
bearing 14 children from his
relationship with ashihara then died of
a heart attack however he passed on the
ritual to someone else which kept the
ritual alive for thousands of years
leaving professor jones's house felix is
unaware that ron follows him and
overheard his conversation with
professor jones
zveotislav and his assistant c felix
being chased by his frantic followers in
the park and immediately recognize him
as the man who failed to flirt with
girls in one of their seminars
meanwhile at felix's office jane comes
to him to mock him again but this time
felix touches her arousing her she tells
him to come to ron's office because the
latter wants to see him at ron's office
ron convinces felix that with his talent
they can work together to excel at their
careers
he asks felix to hide underneath his
sofa but with his hand popping out of
the hole then meets sarah who already
has an appointment with him he positions
himself on the sofa so that sarah
unknowingly touches felix's hand
arousing her but making her think that
she is aroused because of ron and
proceeds to have intercourse with him
felix goes viral with news outlets
broadcasting his abilities and
interviewing his infatuated women
jane who is in james office recognizes
felix when he appears on television
saying that something feels special when
he touches her james deduces that felix
has a special ability with his touch
sarah and her choir are also watching
the news and discussing what kind of
ability felix possesses
ron and zvyatislav are also watching it
and wishing they could possess felix's
ability felix goes to a bar and tries to
talk with desperate men who may want his
ability but no one believes him
unbeknownst to him sveatoslav and his
assistant disguise themselves to
overhear felix's conversation
meanwhile james meets ron and asks if he
can have felix's ability to gain more
votes from the women and ensure his
victory in the upcoming election as well
as repair his relationship with sarah
ron admits that he knows how to get the
ritual which is by performing a silly
dance they try to perform it then james
attempts to touch a woman but he is
smacked on the face ron meets with felix
convincing him to pass the ability to
james so james can get what he wants and
they can excel in their careers
felix is confused by the situation and
meets with professor jones again to seek
counsel he knows that the ability must
only be passed down to someone with a
pure heart otherwise someone can use it
for evil intentions however professor
jones tells him that passing the ability
with someone of a pure heart will only
bring misery to the bearer just like
samyaza and felix have experienced he
suggests felix pass it to someone with
an evil heart because instead of
arousing women it will cause the women
to throw hate and anger toward the
bearer felix is kidnapped by zvyatislav
and his assistant on his way home
felix wakes up in a cult meeting which
turns out to be joined by sarah and
spiotislov
sarah is curious about felix's ability
and demands he touches her so she can
know what it feels like
she is overwhelmed by the sensation and
faints sveatoslav demands felix to pass
the ability to him but just as felix
wants to perform the ritual ron walks in
telling them felix cannot pass the
ability to anyone else because he made a
deal with james svyatislav stabs ron
determined to get the ability no matter
the cost
james also walks in and fights to gain
the ability but zvyatislav defeats him
too the ritual is eventually performed
then felix successfully passes his
ability to svatislav and is freed from
his misery from being endlessly chased
by women
sometime later svyatislav holds a
seminar again he touches the women with
the hope that they will be attracted to
him
however they all turn angry instead then
chase after him to beat him to death
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching